you know with the prison thing like  obviously  you know there's  different politics  in prison than outside of prison would  you say is that accurate um you know i  feel like everywhere you go  you know you step on the metro they have  rules you know what i mean you step on  a bus in the street they have everywhere  you go you're gonna deal with rules  that's just part of the part of life  um  you know  when you get to where you're going  you figure out what's going on and  that's  basically how we roll you know what i'm  saying is like i don't i don't  really  how can i explain i don't  like practice or or you know any of that  i just wherever i get to i'm at  i basically  you know  try to roll with the punches and roll  with what's going on and just go the  right direction and just fly a straight  kite you know